うんうんっ
me
えっ
ええええええ
何かの方ゴミも準備しておりました2
wh
食べる
おっすー
じゃあはいと言うし
うにっ
さぁ今日開いてきて久しぶりの新居でございます始め雪です最近はそんなに東京に来る
ことなくてなかったんですけどもやっぱり週末とばになるとちょっと忙しいので高級に
入ることがありますそれですね俺ねここで生活するキャラない生活する気はないんです
けど
必要最低限のものだとか生活に必要なものはどんどん鑑定行こうと思っている今の
ところですねっ
入ったのかさっき届いてゴミ誠ああっシャンプーリンスお風呂のアナリストん以上です
町駅行も買わないで冷蔵庫のとかは無い前タッキーが欲しいなと思ってるんですけど
ただ実際にですねまたここでどれくらい生活よくわかってないんでそこら辺はちょっと
ばと言われているんだわかっていければなと思っておりますぜひちょっと飽きたらいい
んですけどどんな感じの新歓コンパ
動かしていくかなと思っておりますでは以降ば特にパット見でそんなね超巨大な部屋
ってわけでもないんですけどそこそこ部屋かありますまずはこちらがメインルーム
おそらく撮影とかはこんなにありなるかと思っております
もう来たらキッチン的なところあるんですけどもここら辺をどう使って.考えものです
ねこれ編集日になると思いますよ
出来ちゃってはここからつまり非公開ですねまったく私部屋でございますここがね
とりあえず寝室です
どーん
小型ば寝るだけの部屋ですねちょっと変わるため今中に入れると思うんですけども何も
ありません
かくれんぼに使えそうですねもう一つここに値上がるんですけどもことに感謝またどう
使おうかものでも考えてないです
とりあえずありますうわぁ
完成ですカーテンが全然足りてないんだけど
こちらは何にはないですね細かいももう機とかになるから力が使い道がよくわからない
ありがとうございます
ついにせたことがあるから突発し何か言うこともないんですけど
4 c というのはここを触るおかーしゃるーでございます人はぜひわかったぞ
はいいう感じでお部屋になっております息にこう何かすごい
いうわけでもないんですけどもまぁねちょっと待って撮影するには十分飲みやがった
思いまた者は3方向に出るとちょっとね新しい技術かなって思いました
ありがとうございますというわけでこの部屋で動画を撮ることが増えると思うんです
けどまだ何も置いてないんじゃ
また机とかを何も置いてないので今後ここで同時で撮影スタイルてっていくかっていう
のをちょっとまた考えていこうと思いますペースが良かったらなんかコメント欄でこれ
は買っといていいやーみたいな奴だったら教えてください参考にさせていただきます
ラングジムとか赤ゴールとかは欲しいかもしれないですねだけど今日もちょっと
バタバタしてたんですけど東京でゆっくりお休みします
じゃじゃーん
ん
うっ
goo
wh